let's talk about three groups that i
have that i think this could work for so
if you're going to start picking me i'm
going to start with the bottom one
or i actually think it's the best one
but it's fun i'm on my list
nurses we've talked about nurses a ton
it's an interesting demographic
i think nurses are kind of cool for this
space for two reasons
or three reasons the first work could
pay for it maybe
i think work would maybe pay for it
second
nurses are typically i've spent time
around nurses so they're typically women
and they typically are
people who feel like downtrodden like
they feel like they're forgotten
because they're not worked overworked
underpaid or
underappreciated yeah and that is so
groups that are the um
whatever you just said i guess i don't
know how to explain it but groups that
are like the
us versus them like we don't have
someone speaking for us
typically that's like there's a lot of
like i've looked when i was researching
communities
there's so many successful um women like
women discussing x y and z communities
this is just like that so i think that
they have that uh
us versus their mentality and the third
reason is there's a ton of nurses
yeah have you seen this instagram
account nurse life are in
no how many is it it's 1.2 million
members on instagram
it's run by this guy i think his name is
eb or ebby i'm not sure exactly how you
say his name
and it's this guy this is black nurse
and um
private they just went private uh they
used to be public and i think you have
to like
you have to request so that they can
make sure that you're a nurse before
they let you in
um which again is part one thing that
communities do well
the you know what's that quote it's like
i don't want to be a part of any group
that would accept me
um you know the the better your gate at
the front uh the more people will value
being in the group
and so this is a group and they they
just post mostly like nurse memes
so it's like you know if you it's like
being underappreciated or whatever
they'll make a joke out of it or like
you know coming home and realizing you
still have whatever you know on your
shoe
and uh it's just you know relatable
memes from the eyes of a nurse
so that's how they like keep their
members engaged it's just meme content
that's a good like
inside joke for the community but he
partnered with the makers of
bala shoes which is the nurse shoe brand
that's coming out that's trying to be
nike for nurses basically
it's nike for medical footwear and so he
got
equity in that company and gets paid
every month because he is the
promotional vehicle
for the forbal issues who wants to like
penetrate this community right so
um not a paid community as such but it
is a private community
and on top of that they do this now what
would incredible health
you know the startup that's raised i
don't know how much money 25 million
dollars from
entries and horowitz and all that what
would they pay to access 1.2 million
nurses that are like engaged and trust
this brand
and trust this leader of the community
they would pay a lot
right uh nurse job boards like so so
if this guy's ambitious he could create
a job board he could create the next
incredible health
uh he could take equity and balance
shoes and be a part owner of the shoe
brand like
i think that's where this goes for for
nurses i think that's a great example of
one
i think this could crush i think that
guy is gonna that guy's sitting in a
gold mine that like
if you if you fast forward 10 years and
tell me that he turned this 1.2 million
person instagram page into 100 million
company i won't be surprised
right if you go and start truck life rrn
right now uh i
i think i think that's what's going to
happen after this pod
truck um the second one this is shocking
to me okay
google sheets there's this guy who
tweeted at me and he started this thing
called
sheets con and he had 6 700 people sign
up
is that i mean i guess that's shocking
because
like i know that probably 100 million
people plus use google sheets
but and i guess it doesn't and i guess
it also doesn't track me because i am a
google sheets nerd and like i've
dorked out about what i want and some of
the most uh
profitable online courses in the world
are
become an excel master uh how to use
excel become
better at excel those are like if you go
look at the charts of
uh most profitable online courses
highest revenue online courses excel is
always in the sort of top five
yeah encore the founder of um teachable
teacher one time
one time told me that uh there was some
guy making a million bucks a year and he
was like the biggest earner on teachable
on excel exactly so
google sheets i 100 think you could do a
paid community now it would have to be
cheap though because it's the same
it's the math of like how much money do
you make for google sheets i think that
there's absolutely something there
um and then the last thing is this
someone tweeted at me
a community of vetted senior engineers
who talk about advance advanced
uh engineering concepts like how to
scale a tech stack from 100k to 10
million users
totally buy into that something like
that that is incredibly niche
and incredibly high-end where if there's
a there's this other component that we
didn't talk about with the community is
you have to make it
so that information that you gather in
that group
you cannot find online like um for
tiger21
not that many people are gonna talk
about how like because it's embarrassing
how do i gift my child 15 million
dollars without the government getting
hands on it
like that's not something you're going
to tweet because that's embarrassing
same thing with
100 000 to 10 million users there's just
simply not that many people who have
done it
so you're not going to find a lot of
reputable information on that so that's
another trait of these paid communities
and why i think this one
in particular is interesting i think any
job
in any any job can do this so nurses is
a good one because you have
some are going to be better than others
because you have uh
you know the more people the more
potential and the more
um kind of like insider knowledge is
needed the more
uh downtrodden that group feels i'm
trying this is kind of a negative word
but
kind of what you're saying like sort of
like they feel that they need to take
action
um in order to like level up in some way
uh the better and so like you know this
could work for nurses but it could also
work for designers i could see somebody
just making a community
of you know professional designers at
all these different companies it's like
yep we have designers from figma
and from hubspot and from octa and from
github
and you should if you're a designer at
one of these companies you're making 150
a year 200 000 a year um why would you
not want to be a part of the like the
best network of other designers like you
where you can share
tools tactics salary information if
you're looking for new jobs
opportunities if you're looking for new
jobs like
every job i think needs this and the
more new infringe your job
the more they the more the community is
needed so like i know that our friend
david spinks did this with community
because community was like this there's
not really like there's no chief
community officer at these big companies
but all greek companies say it's all
about community facebook's like it's all
about community
twitch is like it's all about community
and uh what does that mean and who in
your company show me your who's in
charge of community at your company
right and there's typically not a c
level who's in charge of community
so david spinks said well look there's
all these like
kind of mid-level people who are
community
they run community for these big ass
companies and
there's no playbook on how to do their
job they're underpaid they're
underappreciated
and they're overworked trying to run all
these events i'm gonna make the best
community for community professionals
and so he made the community for
community people
it grew pretty large he ended up selling
the thing i don't know how big of a
business it was in terms of a business
outcome he might have been a little
early
but i think that's a great example of
somebody doing this just taking a job
and making it happen
so there's my idea i just wanted to talk
about communities because i think
they're actually kind of cool businesses
i think a lot of people think that they
want to start one
but um i also think that there's a lot
of mistakes made of like charging too
little and i wanted to show a few
examples of companies that make
like a quarter of a billion dollars of
value off communities because i think
they're kind of cool
so that's all i got to say about
communities i'll leave it with this
which is
a lot of people i think the majority of
people who listen to us
they would love a non nine to five way
to make ten thousand dollars a month
and if i was gonna write or uh i read
that in your uh
your survey results yeah um
yeah which we could talk about that but
but in general that's
that's the number one thing i think
people listen to this would would just
grab right away they don't all want to
be founders of billion dollar companies
or 200 million dollar companies or
whatever
um but if i said hey this is something
outside your nine-to-five
it's a side hustle it doesn't take up
all your time and it's gonna bring in
ten thousand dollars a month
i would say that this to me right now is
the number one way to do it
i think there are some other ways right
you could try e-commerce or drop
shipping or something like that you
could try to do a newsletter or paid
newsletter
i would do a community if i was gonna
that would be my fastest path to that
right now
and i'll tell you the reasons why are
all the things you said which is like
it's not that much work to run the
members provide the value to each other
it's not all about you creating content
all the time
it's not that hard to spin up you just
have to be smart about which group
you're choosing and what
where you kind of have an edge what's
your group
and then the last thing the downsides of
it are that it can't scale super large
but that's not your goal anyways you're
just trying to get to ten thousand
dollars a month of free free cash flow
from your side hustle and so that is
super achievable you know
uh 20 a month for for 500 members and
you're there you know
so i think that is where i think this
business fits in
and i and i and i said before i actually
do think they can scale but not all of
them can
some of them some some of them can but i
i'm someone i've built a paid community
that makes
many many millions of dollars a year in
recurring revenue and
it is i would say that it's really hard
actually to start
because i had to create a lot of the
content early on and i had to create the
um the culture of the community but now
i barely post
and it has its own culture so yeah once
it's
once it's taken off yes it you you
create that flywheel and it works or not
by the way i just did this i just did
this in e-commerce and it probably i've
probably put in a grand total of
maybe eight hours into this thing and
i'll tell you what it is so
i wanted to create a community for
people who have ecommerce stores so i
created a gate at the front that said
your ecommerce store must be doing a
hundred thousand dollars a month
it doesn't even have a website there's
no website um it's it's called club ltv
ltv is like an inside term in the e-com
world lifetime value
it's like what every e-com store owner
wants is their their ltv to go up
so i called it club ltv it's people
trying to increase their ltv
and so i said you have to have a hundred
thousand dollars a month of of revenue
i told so i tweeted it out so i
definitely had a head start because i
have an audience so
that brought in about the first 35
members you said yep and they would just
send me a screenshot of their dashboard
yep here's me this morning
okay so so what i did was i made it free
to join for the
uh the store owners but you had to have
this much value like this much
you had to be this kind of far ahead in
the game um but what i did then was i
went to
sponsors and i basically said hey i have
a group of 75
store owners ranging from 1 million to
50 million uh
dollars a year in revenue and all of
them
trust me like me and i meet up with them
once a month and um would you like to
sponsor this so i have one sponsor on
board
they paid me five thousand dollars a
month um all i do is at the event i say
boom i do my intro my high energy intro
and then i say hey let me pass it to
the guy that makes this possible that
makes this group possible and he says
his thing for two minutes
he's had uh i can't say the names but
um i don't know if i should i guess i
just give him a free plug so mercury
bank is the sponsor of it because that's
who
i would use for e-commerce projects and
they're they have a big push in
e-commerce
and so they've had at least from our
group five different
um five out of the 75 e-commerce stores
switched to mercury just from the
sponsorship so they've gotten their
money's worth
out of it including one companies that's
a two billion dollar company has
switched over to them
and so uh you know they definitely got
their value out of the sponsorship
but is this still going yeah this goes
every month and so all that we do
we have we have about one hour a month
of of
prep and then 90 minutes a month of the
actual event
and the one hour of prep is that ben
goes and gets a cameo made from a
different rapper every month
and the rapper's just shouting out club
ltv he's like so we had like
you know um we had uh sean paul
do the cameo one month and he's like hey
it's your boy sean ball just one of the
like
big big ups to club ltv you guys are all
doing so great with your ecommerce store
and he's like you know just
it doesn't even make any sense but it's
just like a video that plays and people
like it because it's like
i don't know it's kind of goofy so we do
one we get one cameo ordered
and he sends the calendar invite so just
make sure everybody gets it sends one
reminder email
and then the last thing is that after
the event he just says hey
if you learned something really useful
that you're going to implement in your
business um email me the one line of the
most useful thing that happened for you
in the hour
because the structure of it is we break
everybody up into groups of six
so you're in a group with six other
store owners who do between 1 and 50
million a year in revenue
and then the the format is you say one
thing you did in the last month that's
really working it's driving revenue up
and one thing that you're struggling
with that you might want help from from
the group
and so afterwards they all email him the
most useful things he just comp he just
takes
he just takes that sheet and he just
sends it to everybody so hey here was
the top insights
from the group so that whole thing takes
in one hour what's that
why wouldn't you charge for that because
because i can actually make much more
off the sponsorships
for example i've been approached by you
know the companies that want you to
build their ecom store on their platform
there's the people who want you to use
them for email marketing there's the
people who want
for influencer marketing who are you
using for facebook advertising who are
using what's the agency that manages
your
your um your data tracking like your
pixel stuff
so all these companies each are willing
to pay multiple thousands of dollars
i just have to onboard them now um
because now i have the group and the
group is where the value is that's the
honeypot
it's the same thing you were talking
about where eventa they have a free
group and they might they have
they are making 25 million dollars a
year on the sponsors
who want to talk more than that oh sorry
that's the profit they're making 200
million but
um that's the same model that i'm using
here don't charge the members just make
sure all the members
have successful businesses and once they
think this is going to get or do you
care
i mean i put zero effort into it since
then but like we have 75 people who show
up every month to the thing
and um which is like 80 85 of the
members show up every single month to
the event so they're getting value out
of it
and so i bet if i told ben hey go on
twitter and just reach out to these 250
cold email these 250 or these 500
e-commerce stores
because it's very easy to get lists of
e-commerce stores that are successful
um i bet we could triple the size of the
group if we if we put some effort into
it but
don't really care about it it's more for
fun but it's cool because it's just free
money every month and
uh it's a good group to be in i want to
learn from these people i want to learn
what they're doing
what's working what's not and make these
connections
that's badass well you uh you know i
it's funny i've i've built the community
as well but it's like every time i learn
something like you the way you're doing
it is a lot different than the way that
we've done it and it's really neat to
hear a different
point of view and perspective uh on how
to get it done
right i optimize mine for how do i spend
the least time but get
just enough value whereas i think for
you is like a part of your business
you're like i'm gonna
this is gonna be a multi-million dollar
thing and we're gonna make it
awesome which is
awesome by the way if i had to start
over i would have done it differently um
i would have charged way more money
right um because i've learned
the mistakes that you have to add a ton
of people to build a big business and a
ton of people for certain groups isn't
necessarily good
right
i feel like i can rule the world
travel never looking back
[Music]
uh